wie können kinder so etwas verarbeiten
das sind unvorstellbare grausamkeiten
ist es überhaupt möglich wenn kinder
jahrelang sexuell missbraucht und
vergewaltigt werden dass sie dieses
trauma irgendwann überwinden
das ist ein großer anspruch ein trauma
in diesem kontext wirklich zu überwinden
sie müssen immer sich so das so
vorstellen dass solche körperlichen und
seelischen grenzüberschreitungen zu
massiven traumatisierungen führen und in
der folge dazu dass zu dem was wir der
traumafolgestörungen und wir gehen auch
davon aus wenn selbst wenn wir dann
solche kinder über lange zeit intensiv
behandeln seelischen narben werden immer
bleiben
wie hoch sind denn die offizielle zahl
und wie hoch vielleicht auch die
dunkelziffern also die zahlen über den
sozusagen zu sexuellen missbrauchs den
letzten jahren eigentlich immer gleich
die offiziellen anzeigen und wir gehen
davon aus dass die dunkelziffer 4 bis 10
fach erhöht ist das ist allerdings kein
neues phänomen sondern dass es die
ganzen letzten jahre schon so was sind
denn anzeichen was kann man tun
naja also wirklich tun kann man in dem
sinne nichts außer besonders aufmerksam
sein dass es eben in dem beitrag auch
schon deutlich geworden dass häufig auch
diese kinder nicht auffallen weil sie
natürlich einen extrem schweigegelübde
unterliegen weil sie ihre eltern nicht
verraten wollen und weil sie denken das
ist sozusagen alles ganz normal
insbesondere wenn sie ihren damit
aufgewachsen sind das mindert den
seelischen schaden nicht ich finde dass
wir manchmal in deutschland so einer
haltung haben dass man wenn man ein
auffälliges kind von nachbarn oder in
der schulklasse sieht dass man so eine
zurückhaltung hat die eltern darauf
anzusprechen und ich würde mir wünschen
dass die mehr aufmerksamkeit und mehr
offenheit haben auch sowas anzusprechen
und das ist keine grenzüberschreitung
ist so jemand anderen zu gehen und zu
sagen du ich habe den eindruck da ein
kind ist irgendwie auffällig kann ich in
die hilfreich sein
gleichwohl darf man sich nichts
vormachen dass man dadurch solche fälle
wirklich verhindern wird
es geht mir darum dass wir aufmerksamer
sind ohne denunziatorischen zu werden
wie gehen sie denn persönlich als
psychiater mit solchen traumatisierten
kinder um also wie muss man sich eine
solche therapie vorstellen
es gibt unterschiedliche frauen der auch
schon zwischen spezifizierten
traumafolgestörungen oder trauma
therapie da gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche ansätze
das eine ist dass man den kindern hilft
das tatsächlich zu überwinden
das andere ist dass man insbesondere
neue perspektiven mit diesen kindern
erarbeitet die das leben erleichtern
haben wir in deutschland eigentlich ein
frühwarnsystem sie haben gerade schon
angesprochen dass man vielleicht der
nachbarschaft im umfeld etwas
aufmerksamer aufmerksam aus tschuldigung
aufmerksamer sein sollte aber gibt es
ein richtiges frühwarnsystem weil die
jugendämter stehen sozusagen immer
bereit hier haben die bieten wir auch in
ganz deutschland an dass man anonymen
anrufen kann wenn man das nicht möchte
und die gehen auch jedem jedem hinweis
nach gleichwohl ist das in dem sinne
kein frühwarnsystem
sexueller missbrauch ist ein nach wie
vor gesamtgesellschaftlich am ende doch
auch gebildetes phänomen nur mit solchen
spitzen wie sie jetzt immer wieder hat
dann auftauchen ist die anhörung sehr
groß aber die vielen einzelfälle von
sexuellen missbrauch die finden
weiterhin statt
aber in diesem fall war der haupttäter
jahr schon jahrelang auf vielleicht hat
ja auch das jugendamt versagt muss nicht
dann auch dort nachgeschult werden
also ich glaube dass wir uns alle noch
viel aufmerksam machen müssen aber sie
müssen sich zum beispiel vorstellen dass
wir in der klinik schon seit jahren
davon ausgehen dass wir zu wenig sexuell
missbrauchte kinder oder mädchen und
jungen sehen und zwar nicht weil die
nicht bei uns sind sondern weil die uns
dass trotz größter aufmerksamkeit
unsererseits nicht sagen
also wir versuchen uns intensiv zu
schulen seit vielen jahren und trotzdem
muss ich davon ausgehen dass wir das
übersehen in anführungsstrichen weil die
kinder trotz größter bemühungen
unsererseits und auch trotz größter
bemühungen ein vertrauensvolles
verhältnis herzustellen so in ihrer
realität gefangen sind dass sie es uns
nicht sagen